I was with you just a few weeks ago at
the Grammy Museum and I said to you you
have the opportunity to make history at
the Grammys and I was right girl
[Music]
congratulations
what do you feel do you feel this pride
yeah I think because the nomination is
like the part that's important because
like it doesn't really matter who wins
it because it's like to be even
nominated at all to be in the realm of
the Grammys in any sort of way is really
like indescribable soul man like for my
whole life and it's I've been saying
even to be here like at the rehearsals
the last couple days I'm looking at the
row that I'm seated in and it's like
every single person that I grew up
watching on TV in that row and I'm I'm
in that role it's like I don't know we
have planned for the performance you see
tell me about the fashion last thing
okay so this is upside the Burberry so
it's all like redone Burberry by
Burberry they made it for me it's all
like old pieces made it
so that's great I want you to rest your
voice because we have a big performance
I'm so happy for you congratulations I
was right
made Grammy history I am always right on
Entertainment Tonight
[Music]